EVERYBODY FOR JOINING US FOR
THIS SPECIAL EDITION OF THE
SENATE CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
IT'S AN OCCURRENCE IN FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
FILE TODAY THAT'S AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM WE WELCOME THE GOODISON
INTO COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
SERGEANTS ARE GONNA BE CALLING
MEMBERS TO INSURE THAT WERE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MR
SOMEONE NEVER GONNA HAVE YOU
KICK US OFF AND THEN OF COURSE
WE'LL SERVICES FIRM IN I GET A
VOTE THE FORESHORE SIR AND
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LOOKS LIKE I'M GONNA KICK YOU
OFF AND IN IN IN THE IN THE
MORNING TO FOR YOU AND I.
APOLOGIZE FOR DRAGGING YOU HEAR
A GOOD EARLY HOUR OF NINE AT
NIGHT. GOOD IT'S GOOD HOME
APPARENTLY EARLY FOR MANY OF
YOU. OF AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE IS THE- ABOUT RETURNING
TO SENATE GOVERNMENT.
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE I'M SURE
YOU ALL REMEMBER THIS BILL. WE
TOOK AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ENSURE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS WILL NOT BE DENIED
BASED ON A PROJECTS
ELIGIBILITY. TO RECEIVE WELFARE
EXCEPTION. OF A FEW CITIES OF
THREATEN TO DENY PROJECTS BY
ARGUING THAT THE PROJECTS WELL
FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS. IMPOSES AN
ADVERSE IMPACT ON PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY SINCE THE. PROJECT
WILL NOT GENERATE ANY PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE. OF THE SIMPLE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
TO THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT AND GOVERNMENT CODE.
SECTION SIX FIVE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT WHICH PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION AND LAND USE
PLANNING. AND PROJECT APPROVALS
CLARIFY. THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE WELL FOR
EXEMPTION IS NOT A LEGAL BASIS
UPON WHICH TO DENY THE PROJECT.
I'D LIKE TO ALSO NOTE THAT MY
OFFICE IS WORKING WITH A CENTER
WIENER CENTER SKINNER ON
CHAPTER OUT AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS COMPLEX WITH SB FIVE
NINE TWO AND SB THREE THIRTY
RESPECTIVELY. I'M SURE WE'LL
HAVE THOSE RESOLVED AND THAT
TESTIFYING HERE TODAY WE HAVE
ANYA LAWLER FROM WESTERN CENTER
AND MAUREEN HAGENS WITH
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING ON MILLER WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINE LONG AGO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT MEET CERTAIN
QUALIFICATIONS ARE ENTITLED TO
BE WELL FOR EXAM FOR PROPERTY
TAX AND THAT PROPERTY TAXES
THAN THAT THE FORGOTTEN
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE BECOMES
PART OF THE SUBSIDY FOR THE
PROJECT. PROJECT SHOULDN'T BE
THREATENED WITH DISAPPROVAL ON
THE BASIS THAT THEIR L. L.
DOUBLE TAKE THAT WILL FOR
EXEMPTION WE BELIEVE THIS IS
JUST A CLARIFICATION AND A MORE
DIRECT WAY TO STATE. WHAT IS
CURRENT LAW AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IGNORING HELP
GOOD HOW ARE YOU. THE MORNING
HIGGINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
THE SPONSOR THIS BILL AND I
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR
AND MY COLLEAGUE I WOULD ONLY
JUST QUICKLY ADD THAT THIS IS
AN- IMPORTANT TO. A TOOL OF
COST. REDUCTION TOOL AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH THE
DIFFICULTY AND LAYER ALL THE
FINANCING THAT THEY NEED IS
ANOTHER IMPORTANT COST
REDUCTION. TOOL TO HAVE IN
THEIR TOOL KIT. YEAH FOR YOUR
EYES. BEING A PROTEST MONEY
WE'RE NOT AN OPEN UP FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD FIRST LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION. MORNING. WHAT'S
GOING ON HOW MUCH RESEARCHER
MEMBERS CAROLING ABOVE THAT I
BURBANK HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION SOCCER ESSAM CINEMA
COUNTY THANK YOU INSOFAR GOOD
TO SEE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WHEN I WOULD LIKE
TO GET A WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY
BE IN A POSITION TO PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME. TO ME LAST OFFER
OPPOSITION THE GENTLEMAN AT
BEFORE WE TURN IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WITH A VERY SPECIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT IT'S INTENSE
BIRTHDAY TODAY SO IN TIME AND
IT'S A VERY SPECIAL TRADITION.
IS GOING TO DO A DANCE IN MY
RIGHT EYE AND TELL. THAT WAS AN
APPROPRIATE HELL NO. HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ANTI. WE WELCOME MR
THAT SAID HEY THAT'S RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT THE SPRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MR LAST YEAR. MR TERRACE SCF
DE. UM REQUIRES PROPERTY OWNERS
TO CHIP IN TO PAY FOR THE
EXISTING DATA THAT. WAS ISSUED
TO PAY FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT NOW WHAT THEY'RE
BENEFITING FROM BUT IF WE
EXEMPTS CERTAIN PROPERTIES THEN
THE OTHER OWNERS WOULD HAVE TO
PAY ANY CRIMINAL. THAT MORE
WATER IN AND SO THEY HAVE TO
TAKE ON THAT. EXPENSE BUT THEY
DON'T REALLY HAVE LIKE A CITY
COUNCIL TO GO TO BECAUSE THE
CFT IS. IT DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
A ELECTED BOARD SO. WHAT WHAT
KIND OF RECOURSE WOULD. A
PROPERTY OWNER HAVE IF THEY
FELT LIKE THEIR TAXES ARE GOING
UP MORE THAN JUST. YOU NOTE. AN
INCREMENTAL I'M OUT THERE
WOULDN'T BE OF ANY CONCERN BUT
MAYBE FOR SOME IT MIGHT BE IT
I'M JUST CURIOUS. TURN THIS
OVER TO OUR EXPERTS TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE A SPECIFIC ANSWER THE
QUESTION BUT I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT WE'RE- HERE FOR PURPOSES
THE AMENDMENTS ONLY. THE THIS
BILLS ALREADY PASSED THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE AND RECEIVED A
MAJORITY VOTE. BUT I. ADOPTED
AS THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUR
QUESTION. YOU. ASK YOURSELF
PLEASE A CENTER MOORLACH AYE.
THE WAY SEE IF THESE WORK IS
IF. THERE IS A PROTEST
MECHANISMS OF A MAJORITY OF THE
PROPERTY OWNERS PROTEST THEN
THEY CAN DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
THAT WAY IF THERE IS NO PROTEST
TO THEN IT IS REQUIRED TO HAVE
A TWO THIRDS VOTE. TO ESTABLISH
THE DISTRICT AND THIS BILL.
WOULD EXEMPTS DOESN'T APPLY TO
ANYTHING BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY
SO IT ALLOWS ANY NEW. COMMUNITY
FACILITIES DISTRICT TO DEAL
WITH THE REVENUE LOSS FROM THIS
AND BALANCE IT AGAINST THE-
pAFFORDABLE HOUSING MAY BRING.
THE LOCALITY THROUGH REDUCE
SOCIAL SERVICES COST FOR
EXAMPLE. HIS SERVICES PROSPECT
OF YES. AND THERE IS A VIABLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR IMPACTED
TAXPAYERS TO. REACTIVE THEY
FELT THAT THIS WAS. IN SOME
WHICH IT SHOULDN'T BE THIS
SHOULD JUST BE A SMALL LITTLE
PROPERTY SOMEWHERE IN A-
LARGER. POPULATION BUT THERE IS
AN IMPACT. AS YOU ALLOCATE THE
COST EVERYBODY'S OF. SORRYALL
YOU KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE
GOOD TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE
SOMETHING THEY ARE INDEED IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE. ASSUMED
BY ALL THE OTHER RESIDENTS OF
THE. COMMUNITY FACILITIES
DISTRICT. THANK YOU MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS BEFORE WE ASK FOR
CLOSING COMMENT FROM THE SUMMER
WITH A FAILED TO ESTABLISH
WARM. THIS WINCHESTER'S RIGHT A
ROLE WHICH COLOR MCGUIRE HERE.
WHERE PRESENT MORE LOCK. WE'RE
LIKE PRESIDENT BELL. THE
PRESENT HERTZBERG RICARDO.
PRESIDENT NELSON WIENER COM IS
BEEN ESTABLISHED MEMBERS WE
WILL NOT BE SEEN I DO NOT
BELIEVE A CENTER HERTZBERG AS
WELL CENTER NIELSEN COMMITTEE
TODAY WE ARE ON THE HUNT FOR
CENTER WIENER WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TURN OVER TO THE SOME
NEVER FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
ALLOWING ME TO LEARN A LITTLE
BIT. TO ABOUT MY BILL THAT I
DIDN'T KNOW. AS SOMETIMES
HAPPENS. I THINK THE BOTTOM
LINE AS YOU PUT IT IS THAT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT. BUT
WILL PROMOTE THE GREATER GOOD.
OF EVERYBODY WILL PUT A LITTLE
BIT OF THE POT IF YOU WILL. OF
THE GREATER GOOD IS SERVED TO.
BUY A OF THE MECHANISM THAT SET
UP A BY VIRTUE OF THIS BILL.
THAT SAID I DON'T KNOW WHY MISS
LAWLER IS HOARDING THE CANDY.
AT NINE AM IN THE MORNING.
HELLO MY NAME. WHEN IT WHEN IT
WHEN IT SHOULD LEGITIMATELY BY
ALL RIGHTS GO TO ANTON. EXACTLY
HE DID THE DANCE THEMSELVES
YEAH. BUT IT IS IT WORTH IT
THAT AND THAT ON HIS BEHALF I
WOULD BESEECH YOU TO CUT HIM A
LITTLE ADMINISTRATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE YOUR GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE WORKING THE
WITNESSES AS WELL WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER TO MATT
SENATOR BELL THE MOTION IS
RETURNED THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FLOOR THIS LANCASTER CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF WIRES HI WHERE
I'M MORE A LOT. MORE LIKE GOD
THEY'LL THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG.
ANNOUNCEMENT PLEASE IN HIS
ASCENSION OF THE LATEST
INDIVIDUAL. SO IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE OR TODAY. AND I'M STILL HAVE
YEAH WHAT IS IT NUMBER THREE
YES SO. SENATOR WIENER AND. I
LIKE TO REMAIN AT NUMBER THREE
THAT'S RIGHT WE'RE GONNA I
THINK IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
LOOKING TO THE SENATORS HERE
TWO DAYS AND THAT WE HAVE THE
LATEST SENATOR WARD AND THEN WE
HAVE TWO THAT ARE EVEN SHOWED
UP SO THAT SB VERY SPECIAL
AWARD. AS WELL. ALL RIGHT HER
TITLES ARE ALL IN HEY THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA SAY THANK
YOU TO OUR MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRWE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN HERE
MOMENTARILY FOR CENTER WIENER.
IT IS A FORCE HERE WE WILL BE
HAVING A SECOND HEARING ON
FRIDAY OF THIS WEEK. SO THERE
WILL BE ANOTHER HEARING THIS
FRIDAY. MOST LIKELY AFTER
SESSION FOR GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE THIS WEEK SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT EVERY ONCE
IN THE LOOP ON THAT. I AND I'M
LOOKING TO COMMON THERE IS AS
MANY AS- SEVENTY EIGHT BILLS
THAT ARE FLOATING AROUND THE
UNIVERSE THAT I'M WILL BE SEEN
EITHER. INTO THE FRIDAY AND OR
FIRST THING NEXT WEEK AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
MEMBERS AND WE'LL BE BACK WITH
YOU
. YOUR YOUR- YOUR BILL WAS I
THINK WITHOUT A- YOU'RE ALREADY
DOING. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I
HE IS THE WINNER OF THE AWARD
TODAY THAT IS SENATORS GOT
WIENER AT CENTER WIENER I'M WE
ALSO PRESIDED WE PROVIDED AN
ADDITIONAL TWO WORDS TODAY
BECAUSE CENTER HERTZBERG AND
SENATOR NIELSEN THE SECOND.
SHOW SO THERE WE GO. A HEARING
ON. HE IS OBJECTING ALRIGHT
HAZY THERE WE GO ALL RIGHT THE
TIDES. LAZY GENTLEMEN AND BY
THE WAY TEN TIMES PER DAY TODAY.
HEY THERE YOU GO IT'S GOOD
STUFF. YOU SAY HE'S FORTY SEVEN
ALRIGHT HERE WE GO ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SIR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ESTIMATES.
WIENER WIENER AYE THERE IS A
FIVE ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE PLAYS IN
GERMAN WE WILL SEE YOU COMING
UP ON FRIDAY TIME OF THE
HEARING TO BE DETERMINED BUT
WE'LL BE COMMUNICATING A. S. A.
P. WERE VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL
OF YOU COMING TOGETHER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE JERK